because a little a little black woman
walking and spraying stuff on the
sidewalks and trees a New Jersey man
calls police on a nine-year-old girl
spraying for bugs outside
no no you're not in trouble it
in October when Gordon lost she called
non-emergency police in Caldwell New
Jersey he
black woman sprang stuff on the
sidewalks and trees I don't know what
the hell she's doing scares me though
body camera video shows an officer
arriving to the scene to find a
nine-year-old girl spraying for lantern
flies the state of New Jersey has a
campaign called stomp it out encouraging
people to kill invasive species that are
harmful to trees what's that
oh what are you using to sponsor you're
trying to catch him
to the girl
someone just called in and said that she
was alone spraying something on the
grass
yeah the responding officer tells Joseph
her daughter is quote obviously fine to
be spraying for bugs this ain't that
little question for me when I thought
wow
she's obviously fine saying he's
required to write a report the officer
takes down Joseph's information he
appears shocked to find that she and her
daughter live across the street from the
caller what's your address 12 Elizabeth
12.
here okay yes I'm saying we are poor
you're obviously next door neighbors
right the girl then asked she is in
trouble
[Music]
how many did you kill how many trees did
you save they're bad they're all over
the
place's attorney says he has since
apologized to Joseph and her daughter
but has received threats and racist
accusations Joseph and her daughter
spoke at an area city council meeting
saying quote racism intentional or not
is still racism for the latest
developments in this case and all things
True Crime stay with long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie